I start telling people I was doing the
direct-to-dvd sequels a lot of people
were saying that Lion King 2 actually
was okay and yeah I feel what they're
talking about it's probably the best way
to describe okay is it the first film no
but it develop medical world no not good
not bad it's not incredible but it's not
awful either it's a perfect
middle-of-the-road film that you would
probably expect Simba Nala has given
birth to a bouncing baby girl named
Kiara voiced by Neve Campbell so much
shows are the ropes just like his father
did but it turns out there's a dark
shadowy place that they need to stay
away from no not the hyenas now it's the
outsiders a group of lions that like the
leadership of scar and vowed to get the
land back their leader named Zira is
training a lion cub named Koh who to be
a cold-blooded killer who grows up kill
Simba and ultimately takes control why
in well apparently he's a not descendant
from scar yeah it's a little confusing
he's not his son but scar took him in as
his own even though there was never
anything the last movie that show they
did it's pretty forced and stupid but
don't we make some message in the end so
much stronger Kiara
of course befriends Kovu but they're
told that they're going to grow up to be
natural enemies a few years pass and
seemingly it was like oh who wants to
leave his pack having saved Kira's life
and using that as leverage to join Simba
what they don't know is that Kovu is
actually planning to kill him but when
he has the chance let you know it the
two just happened to get along and of
course fall in love and that makes
things really complicated will love
prevail in the two warring sides see
their faults is this as clear a metaphor
for Romeo and Juliet as the first one
was for Hamlet personally I think it's
clever that they're taking from
Shakespeare's second biggest play after
his first biggest play apart from a few
other things but Nathan re the old
characters like Simba Timon Pumbaa and
Zazu all feel kind of recycled even with
the original voice actors coming back
but the new characters and their voice
actors seem to breathe this very
likeable life into them I really like
the people they got to play the new part
where the original actress well not all
bad just kind of feel like they're doing
their usual shtick
Rafiki has a song that doesn't really
add much
since that has a cool dream sequence but
outside of that he's just kind of the
mean father
now let's practically pointless Timon
and Pumbaa well I'd even like that much
in the first film so now the sequel we
get the table scraps of that comedy but
everyone else really seems to care about
this story even if it doesn't always
make sense it's almost cool to compare
the animation of this one to the
original as the original was one of the
biggest anime and movies ever made it's
just huge it's one of the few films
where they rerelease it I go to see it
on the big screen every time now we have
that animation budget cut in half and
what do you expect it's direct-to-video
as director video goes it's not bad they
still have some of that nice line work
and try to work in some good backgrounds
but yeah you're always going to be
comparing it to how good the first one
look and that's always going to be a
little distracting but honestly for what
it is it's pretty beautiful the songs
are surprisingly kind of like I even
found myself humming some of them after
the movie was done we are one is a nice
melody in depending while pointless is
still a nice rhythm and even the song he
listened you I think that's in the
Broadway version isn't it so you know
that's got to be pretty solid in many
respects the film doesn't need to exist
the first Lion King truly was a
spectacle to look at and when you do a
direct-to-dvd movie that's trying to
capture something similar you know
you're not going to get it so it almost
seems pointless but if I was forced to
make a directed video sequel on the Lion
King this is probably what I would turn
into there is a lot of effort in what
I'm sure is not a lot of time and not a
lot of money at least by Disney Feature
Film standards is it awkward at times
yeah but it does have enough character
to it that even though I felt like I
knew what was going to happen I still
wanted to see it happen
if it was a feature film I'd probably be
a little harder on it but since it's a
direct-to-video movie I think it's okay
it gave me exactly what I expected and
nothing really more but I wasn't
expecting more if anything I was
expecting what if you want to see
something on par with the first Lion
King you're definitely not going to get
that here but honestly I don't know
anyone who thinks they're going to get
that if you want to see sort of a TV
sequel with better than TV animation I
is one fine kind of a middle-of-the-road
review but it's kind of a
middle-of-the-road pop it in and judge
for your phone
you
[Music]